let's bring in Kira rudick here she's a
member of the Ukrainian Parliament and
is head of the opposition hollow's party
she joins us from Kiev welcome to the
program tell us how is your country
holding up after 10 months of War
hello thank you so much for having me as
you see no matter how hard it is right
now without the electricity without the
heating without the running water and
with constant air raid attacks we are
holding up we are pushing Putin's forces
back and we are doing things that nobody
believed we would do at the very
beginning of the full-scale invasion
this 10 months have been incredibly hard
on our people however there were so many
things that thought to be impossible
that became possible starting from Kiev
standing up for more than two three days
uh that put in set it up to be conquered
at second with us having the candidacy
to European Union something that critics
did not believe would happen of course
nobody believed that we were capable of
pushing Russia back and taking cities
like Harrison to uh to be back to
Ukraine right and right now uh the the
year is ending with president's speech
at the Congress and talking to the
President Biden so no matter how hard we
are motivated
and plan to win the war next year
well winning the war of course depends
on getting support from other countries
the U.S has taken the lead in providing
Aid and weaponry for Ukraine that was
underlined by your president's trip to
Washington this week but what about
Europe are you convinced that the EU
including Germany is doing all it can to
help Ukraine
though we are extremely grateful for
everything that is being done for us
starting from humanitarian aid financial
aid sanctions and weapons there is lots
of uh things that could be done uh
additionally especially it is uh it is
concerning that there are so many
requests on the weapons that are not
being fulfilled and we do hope that
while the U.S is taking lead on
providing Ukraine with the most
sophisticated weapons defense weapons
the missile systems that we need to
protect ourselves from their missile
attacks from Russia we also would hope
that European countries will follow this
lead and give us the necessary means to
protect ourselves to make sure that once
the Russian missiles are being launched
we know definitely that we are able to
intercept them and we are able to
protect not only our critical
infrastructure but also people people
who struggle every single day
Ukrainian Parliament Cara rudick there
thank you very much for talking with us
thank you and glory to Ukraine
well this holiday season is a struggle
for ukrainians Russian airstrikes have
cut power disrupted water supplies and
knocked out Heating and the war has
broken up families sending Millions
abroad and many to the front CW's Max
sander met up with a family in Kiev
enjoying an unexpected Christmas gift
a bit of a holiday spirit
and a break from the war
iulia brought her kids Kira and Daddy to
kiev's only Christmas Market it's
five-year-old's first time on the ice
and brings back memories of her own
childhood
when I lived in Russia in barshortustan
very often the entire Street was frozen
and we used to skate very often
did you like it
yes it was scary though
a recreation of the magic that takes
place in the North Pole with candles
presents
and music
[Music]
Santa is always on his great Throne
listening to the children's wishes Kira
and Dotties are different this year
shorter and truth be told impossible for
Santa to fulfill
victory for Ukraine and a robot
Victory to Ukraine I will not ask for
anything else
Christmas is different this year for
Yulia Christmas usually means spending
time with family visiting her parents
and in-laws celebrating and unwinding
this year Millions have fled the country
are displaced or living under Russian
occupation tens of thousands of families
have lost their loved ones both soldiers
and civilians it is impossible to relax
completely but it is good for the kids
to see that there is not only evil in
this world but also good there are
things to live for there is a desire to
make this a holiday
we put up a Christmas tree and we are
going to celebrate anyway
it tries to comfort them as best she can
but she doesn't hide anything the
children know what war means and what
their father does on the front line
I'm really worried he is a medic he
knows how to deal with bleeding but if
he has a bigger wound as well as another
person who is injured he will try to
rescue the other person and not himself
foreign
[Music]
in the dark
there is no power
and time to see Dad exceptionally back
from the front for a routine medical
checkup
the elevator's out so it's walk up 16
floors to see him
dimitro is just back from the hospital
there's been a small Christmas miracle
he's found out he won't have to return
to the front line
right away
foreign
for me every Christmas is special
because the children are growing each
year they're changing and it's the
moment you can see the changes in life
how the year passed by
Christmas and New Years are a kind of
summary of the year you can see what
kind of father you were and what kind of
situation your family was in
um
right now it's a family reunited by
surprise for a wartime Christmas one
they are determined to make as memorable
and meaningful as they can
Alicia fasalenko joins us she is a
lawyer a member of the Ukrainian
Parliament for the opposition holos
party welcome you posted a photo of you
and your children this week and allowed
us to share it with our viewers you
evacuated your kids in March but you
brought them back home for Christmas
tell us why
well Christmas is a time of unity it's a
time to be with family uh to share that
light and when my husband and I we
discussed what to do over Christmas
there was no doubt about it that we
wanted the children to be with their
grandchildren that we wanted the whole
family to sit together at the big family
table uh at our parents house with uh
with the Christmas meal and give it to
sense of normality despite all the
abnormal that has been brought into our
lives by this war that Russia is waging
against Ukraine and of course the
children played that part because they
were absolutely desperate for all this
time to come back home to see their
family their friends so all these
factors played their role and here we
are but coming back home unfortunately
to uh to a home in the middle of a war
in a war zone coping with um disruptions
to power heating water I mean
um it doesn't sound easy
it's not trust me living in the war zone
it's it's not easy it's definitely not
the place for children to be at but
there's um you know there's a mental
health versus uh physical uh physical
safety which shows stay here and as a
mother I am well aware of that but it's
a risk I was willing to take because to
be honest my older son who's nine years
old he was almost in breakdowns over uh
this uh fall semester or over Autumn uh
just asking every day when we can go
back home and that he can't take this
anymore it's not that he didn't like
doesn't like where he lives now his new
school he has friends there he's doing
quite well but it's just this home
sickness was emphasis on the word
sickness which prevails and I think this
is the case with many many of those
people who have ever had to flee their
home because of the war and were forced
to live somewhere else when it's not
your decision when it's something that
is forced upon you this is what is
extremely difficult excruciating even on
the psyche and on the mental health
is there more hope now that president
zielinski has traveled to the U.S to uh
to drum up support
I'm very confident that our president
has come back with good news with the
strategy to increase Ukraine's defense
capacities and counter offensive
capacities and I am very hopeful maybe
it's wishful thinking here but that by
end of spring maybe mid-summer 2023 we
will see Russian soldiers out from the
territory of Ukraine all of the
territory of Ukraine that's 1991 borders
Crimea included there's a long way to
that a long way which depends largely on
the capabilities of the Ukrainian
military supported by a mobilized West
who are able to give us missiles thanks
uh air defense systems who are able to
give us the ammunition to go with all
these sophisticated weapons and not the
least it also depends on on Germany and
the German government being able to to
provide us the weapons that we are
asking for we are grateful for the iris
T system that's the air defense system a
very powerful one that Germany has uh
already provided for Ukraine but we will
need more of those we hope that the
production uh line and speed increases
and we also very very much hope that
Germany will finally make the decision
to give the tanks to Ukraine finally
your message to ukrainians with family
members on the front lines
stay strong believe in the armed forces
of Ukraine believe in good and that good
it always prevails over evil and Ukraine
will win this existential Victory will
be ours and by ours I mean of all the
free Democratic world
Ukrainian parliamentary member Lucia
fasalenko thank you for being on our
show today
thank you